le 1er août sur l'autoroute c'est
vraiment la grosse journée la grosse
journée pour le psg lequel peut avoir 20
ans et être un simple saisonniers
qui perçoit qui se fait
engueuler
qui à faire aux grincheux et
j'apprends peut-être beaucoup plus qu'à
l'université
vous appelez comment
nous prenons ces étudiants adultes et on
et ce jargon signifie qu'aux arts et
techniques de commercialisation
vous en faites de l'appeler mercia lisa
sion assure le vin est ce que c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve pas mal de monde on
retrouve à 2 parce que maintenant
on est tout à fait dans le commerce et
le premier route aujourd'hui vous avez
j'ai vécu une journée assez sportive
assez sportive
mais attendez qu'on avoir un peu plus de
monde ce fut un peu plus chargé qui a
par exemple mais là ça va encore il ya
le courant ascendant et corps en
descendant les anciens va te confier les
futurs vacanciers bas ici on voit
surtout les gens qui remonte sur baril
alors c'est les gens qui ont une tête un
peu triste épisode
tu rentres dans la grisaille de
et ils sont tristes en général oui c'est
vrai et est ce qu'ils ont sur la
province sur la côte atlantique sur
bordeaux pour les voit pas beaucoup doit
cesser sur les personnes qui passent de
l'autre côté qui prennent des tickets
mai en général
sans nier que soient ses esprits en toi
ils sont plutôt souri un plutôt souri un
os les gens qui pleurent et gentil n'y
en a pratiquement cessé les deux
extrêmes selon chances des voitures
lorsqu ils payent et il fait il y avait
des gros billets les petits billets
grâce à ça dépend de la position dans le
mois quand tu es le début du mois et les
gens qui partent
c'est
ibro billet on voit vite ça rassemble
200 puis en général quand les gens on
revienne en provence a donné lapointe
juste là en petite monnaie antiques
manière générale ça c'est marrant de
france a fait ça ils sont un peu un peu
juste à la fin des vacances
oui et puis ils font un peu plus la tête
dans picot sur un porte monnaie pour
payer plutôt qu'au début vous arrivez à
quelle heure le matin savary
on fouille à 3-3 forme de postes de nuit
le matin on est et le soir mais je suis
aussi possibilité de venir en renfort si
donc ça va arriver
une journée sur notre travail